Castine in Maine is a typical New
England port but around the bend from
its harbor there is a rare sight
the only offshore wind turbine in the
United States the US is far behind other
countries like the UK which already has
large offshore wind farms the
conventional sort fixed to the seabed
but political resistance in the US is
softening if offshore wind farms do you
become commonplace in the US some
believe floating turbines will be a key
to helping the country harness its fast
offshore wind resource floating wind
turbines have been investigated by many
it's a very hot research area right now
in the in the world the reason why
people are looking at floating wind
turbines is that a very great deal of
the wind resource in the United States
and elsewhere lies over what we call
deep waters these are water depths over
60 meters as you get above 60 meters
those foundation styles which are fixed
to the seabed become less economical so
floating system can get the cost of
offshore wind down the turbine at
Castine is a 1/8 scale model of a 6
megawatt turbine that's destined to be
deployed further off the coast the test
version will help researchers to predict
how the real thing will fare in wind and
waves this one a scale model deployed at
this test site will simulate the
behavior of a 6 megawatt floating
turbine further offshore the prototype
in addition to being one a scale is also
constructed of the same materials and
was constructed in and deployed in
exactly the same way as a 6 megawatt so
not only are we learning about the
behavior of the system but also about
the materials design and construction
and appointment some 500 kilometers
southwest of Castine is a project hoping
to take advantage of the strong winds
off the coast of Cape Cod Massachusetts
by erecting 130 conventional turbines so
what you're looking at is the
construction of a first elimination
facility it's we call it the New Bedford
marine commerce turn
and from this location we're going to
change the world because from here the
first offshore wind project in the
United States will deploy it will be the
Cape Wind project though Cape Wind
claims that could produce 75% of the
electricity for Cape Cod skeptics
question whether it makes economic sense
there is some positive attributes with
offshore wind in the fact that it's zero
emissions it creates local jobs and
potential for manufacturing but it is a
higher cost energy right now but like
we've seen with solar like we're seeing
with onshore wind we have seen as
deployment has come to scale we've seen
those costs come down if the same
happens for offshore wind facilities
like this one in New Bedford would be a
magnet for the industry but it remains
to be seen whether the idea will take
off for now has teens experimental
floating turbine is the only one in the
water in the u.s. time will tell if it's
a sign of things to come or just a
fleeting curiosity
you